les championnats d'europe de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines juste terminée
l'heure est au bilan pour l'équipe de
france les tricolores ont réussi à
séduire le public du vélodrome nationale
après le fiasco des jo de rio l'été
dernier les pistes a remporté sept
médailles dont trois en or avec une
équipe rajeunie au delà du bilan des
médailles c'est sur toi habile anges
l'équipe d'état d'esprit avec des jeunes
avec une génération que l'on souhaite
accompagner et derrière une émulation
qui s'est créé une équipe qui qui vit
ensemble et qui vit bien ensemble
plus que le paris des médailles on se
rend compte que ben y en a qui sont déjà
au rendez vous
effectivement on en veut toujours plus
un moment donné mais je pense que sur
cette année post olympique avec les
profils pour souhaite cibler pour
préparer l'avenir
c'est un très beau bilan on peut
toujours faire mieux
on est sur un championnat d'europe on
est avec la jeune génération
c'est un travail de long terme on peut
peut-être faire mieux on a déjà fait un
très bon résultat
le saint quentinois quentin lafargue a
profité de la mise à l'écart de françois
pervis de grégory baugé pour s'imposer
en leader de cette équipe de france à
seulement 25 ans le pistard a raflé la
médaille d'or sur le km en devançant de
deux dixièmes l'allemand eric anglaise
c'est très important
et voilà je suis très très très contente
pour le par rapport au travail que j'ai
pu faire je suis un coéquipier qui se
font dans une équipe de france qui est
en train de se recréer suis du coup bas
j'étais plus jeune l'année dernière j'ai
un des plus dans cette année et ben
voilà j'ai un petit peu d'expérience
mais je me propose pas en leader je
prépare mes objectifs et j'essaie d'être
le plus performant possible
la médaille la plus prometteuse a été
remporté par l'équipe de poursuite par
équipe emmenée par l'expérimenté sylvain
chavanel 37 ans et le trappistes
benjamin thomas 21 ans le saint
quentinois également remporté le bronze
sur l'omnium et l'argent sur
l'américaine avec morgan kneisky
j'habite à cinq kilomètres du vélodrome
donc la piste on la connaît par coeur on
s'entraîne un mois je m'entraîne tout le
temps ici donc c'est vrai que ça fait
plaisir
ma famille qui étaient ici ma copine et
où donc c'est top
charlie conord et lui la belle surprise
de cette semaine saint-quentinoise
l'ancien champion du monde junior 2008
s'est rassuré après plusieurs années
compliquées en remportant la médaille de
bronze sur le keirin
ça fait un moment que je courais sur ses
podiums est sûre ce n'est au niveau
international
j'espère maintenant que ça va être plus
qu'un début et que tout se passera pour
le mieux sur le soudan sera sue de la
saison l'année prochaine les
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste se tiendront à berlin en allemagne
les pistards français reprendront la
compétition le 4 novembre à glasgow pour
l'ouverture de la coupe du monde